よろしくお願いします
今までなんか耳障りのいい言葉いろいろ聞いてきたんですよ
これからかなり厳しい私の雑談な話になりますけど
今日のテーマは一応仏教は習うより慣れるということなんですね
実践的体験的仏教の入門
これは日本のことわざで
習うより慣れる方がいいというのは一般的な
まあ日本の社会の文化の考え方で
だからそういう文化的な
一般的に我々理解している
理解できている考え方から
ブッダの世界にアクセスできるかできないかと
ブッダの世界を理解できるかできないかということで
だから これまでは皆様知ってますね
タイトルの意味は  まあ似ていることわざっていうのは英語でもあることはありますけどね
英語であるのはこの完成するんだよとね
まあ慣れることっていうか
プラクティスですね プラクティスメイクパーフェクトということでね
あの 実践することであんたはパーフェクトになりますよと
勉強しただけではという
あまり役に立ってないということになります
だから意味は似ています
それからまあ その角度で
この尺度で まあブッダの教えにちょっと挑戦してみようかなということで
で まず私はこのきつい道でハードウェイラーニングと習うということは
かなりきつい道であるというテーマにするんです
で 習う学ぶとは一概に楽しいものだとは言えない
こんなのは誰でも知ってます
勉強するということは
もうそんなに随分楽しいことじゃないんですね
それから勉強はそれはそれでまだ勉強っていうのは嫌いな人もいるんですよ
もう嫌や やりたくないんだと
勉強は好きと言っても
何でも好きではありません
また じゃあ私は勉強好きだよという人もいますよ
いるんだけど その人はもう何でも勉強好きなわけじゃないんですよ
ある一部何かやりたいだけの話なんですね
それから どんな人にも
好きな人にも嫌いな人も苦手な勉強もあるんですよ
まだ苦手なものもある
それでだからといって好きなことだけ勉強すれば良いと誰も言ってくれません
誰かが言ってくれるんだったら
あんた好きなことだけ勉強すればいいよと言ってくれないんですよ
そういう問題は我々にある
勉強そのものが結構きつい
まあ楽じゃない で それとまた
例えば 10人が集めたら
まあ 5人が勉強は好きやとかもしれませんだけど
また 5人が嫌だ 嫌いだとも言うかもしれません
そうすると 物事ちょっとうまくいかないんですね
それから この 5人の勉強好きな人の中でも
何でも好きじゃないんですよ
例えば学校で考えれば
ある子は数学は好きはあることは子供は絵を描くことが好きかもしれません
ある子供は歴史が好きで
数学は大嫌いかもしれません
そこでまた大変いろいろトラブルが起こる
そういうわけで 勉強好きな人にも自分に苦手な勉強もある
だから苦手なものはやめちゃえばいいんだけど
そううまくいかないんですよ
苦手でも難しいことだとやらなくちゃいけない勉強もある
それでどうトータル的に計算しても
勉強は楽な道じゃないんですよ
こういう世界でしょ 我々生きてるのは
だから勉強は楽々やというふうなことはなかなか言えないんです
それで何が起こるかというと
このハードな道と この勝ち組負け組という
今大変流行っている 流行ってるかどうか
もう死にかけてる言語なんで
もうそろそろ で 勝ち組負け組というね
言葉あるでしょ これが勉強は生み出しますよ
当たり前で で これはもうハードパーツペースウェイトビナーサンルーセスということでもうやっぱり勝ち組負け組に分かっちゃうんですね
習うもの 学問などが自分が好きなものなら簡単に上達できるでしょう
そこで勉強しようと思ったら
何か習おうと思ったら
これ自分が大好きなものだったらみるみるうちに上達しますね
これは当たり前わかります
それで勝ち組になる可能性はあります
音楽に才能ある子供は音楽学校に行ったらもう当たり前
勝ち組になるんですよ
音楽の才能ないのに 親が音楽学校にもう強引に入れてしまえば負け組になるんですね
しかし 簡単という理由で気が抜けたら負け組のメンバーになり得る
これありますよ そんな勉強
私には簡単 ちょろいやと思って気が抜くんですよ
勉強に 真面目に宿題しないとかね
あんなの知ってるんだとかね
なんとかそこちょこちょこっと気が抜いたところで大変なことになる可能性もある
それでまた負け組になってしまう可能性もあります
難しくても学問にチャレンジして上達すると勝ち組に入ります
そこでも苦労を気にせず
いくら難しくても もう徹夜してでも逆立ちしてでも眠くなってくると
もう勉強して頑張れば
まあなんとか勝ち組には入れます
そういうふうな社会なんですね
そこまで一応知っている
だから まあそこから言いたいのは
もうたとえ勉強難しくても
負け組に入ってはいけないんだと
時々私は聞いたのは この子供たちは勝ち組負け組
ある社会もね 会社もなんだかんだも勝ち組負け組に分けるのはどういうことか
それはいけないんではないかと
仏教はそう見てないんではないかというふうな
これは皆様方のご意見であって
別にあるんだからね 勝ち組負け組は
あるんだったらもう勝ち組に入るのは当然当たり前のことでしょうに
だから仏教はどう言います？どう言いますか？と聞くと
答えは簡単です 勝ち組に入りなさいよ
その差は消せませんよ
だからちょっとかっこつけて
そんな区別は良くないんだと
それでも会社 社会で社会人が大変なストレス溜まってるんだと
学校で子供たちは勝ち組負け組考え方でもう大変困っているんだと
だからでどうやって消せるんですかね
だからもうちょっと苦労してでも
もうやっぱり勝ち組に入らなくちゃいけないんですよ
もうしょうがないんで
それは そこで私はもうもう言ってないんだ
裏で言いたいことはこういうことなんですよ
こういう学問の世界 この習う世界が社会の差別を作るんですよ
社会は平等になりません
それなんです 言いたいの
皆平等にはなりませんということ
だからノーイークオリティインソサエティ
社会というところでは
もうイークオリティ 平等ということはありえないんです
ハードな道によって人は能力あるなしに分かれます
この学問の世界で 勉強の世界で
研究の世界で 我々は能力ある人
能力ない人にどうしても分かれてしまうんですよ
競争する気持ちにもなります
そうするとお互いに仲間で競争することもあり得るんですね
あの人よりは何とかして才能はもう向上しなくちゃいけないんだと
点数はいくらかでも誰よりも高い点数を取らなくちゃいけないんだと
いうふうに競争する現象も現れてくる
競争で必ず能力ある人が勝すとは限りません
これが問題ですよ 文章は簡単ですけど
裏の言ってることは大変難しいんです
例えば試験の 試験というのは競争ですよ
だって 合格する人も落第する人もいるんだから
まあ一部落第するために試験やってますよ
そんなのはごまかしはできません
試験というのは残酷なもので
誰の首を切って捨てるのかということをもう考えていて
試験作るんですよ いわゆる誰が選んで誰を捨てるのかと
そうすると試験合格するっていうことは才能でしょ
だからって才能ある人を必ずしも合格するってことじゃないんですよ
競争の世界で これまた問題なんですよ
競争して能力ある人が必ず勝すんだったら文句はありませんよ
全然文句はない 誰も文句言いません
例えば能力の世界で 見事に歌唱能力を持ってる人が
抜群に歌唱能力を持っている
持っている人が歌手になっても誰も文句言いません
その人が来て歌ってくれても
もう感動してありがたがるだけで
それで音痴な人が歌手になるとありがたいんですかね
もうろくに声は出せないし
あちこち間違うし またあらゆる工夫をしてからくりをして
時にやっているのはこのバックグラウンドありますね
バックバックコーラス
あれ バックコーラスというのはなかなかものすごい上手ですよ
もう楽器みたいですよ
声は楽器のために使ってるんだから
そこでも最悪下手な人が真ん中ドーンと立って
体はブリブリ振りながらもう聞きたくもない声で歌っていて
なんとかあの楽器とバックコーラスのおかげで聴いていられる
なんか私なら文句言いたくなるんですよ
あのバックコーラスの方々に歌わせたらどうでしょうかと
本当にあの いろいろ調子を合わせて歌っていると
すごい綺麗だなと 思っちゃうんですよ
だからこの競争で必ずしも能力ある人が勝すということじゃないんですよ
だから不公平な方法で勝ってる人もいます
ないと思う？試験にしてもカニングもできるし
大学入学でも裏口入学もあるし
こんなのは一つ二つバレるんですけど
だからそっちをやってると思いますよ
ちょっとお金が入ってる封筒なんかちょっと裏で渡しちゃえば
うちの子はちゃんともう合格とかね
それは学問の世界で では
一番大事なのは政治なんですよ
我々を管理支配してるんだから
では 政治の世界でいつでも才能ある人
能力ある人 正直な人 国のためにも必死で献身的に頑張りたい人を勝てると思いますよ
選挙は この選挙制でっていうのは
もう一番悪い人を選べるように
資格のないだらしない人が勝てるようにというシステムなんですよ
だってアホな連中の機嫌を取っちゃえばいいし
マスコミを機嫌取っておけばマスコミはチヤホヤしてくれる
それで勝っちゃいますよ
あるいは地方だったらもう顔知られてる
知られてるんだから 親戚同士でしょうし
もういくらなんでも投票せざるを得ないでしょうね
うちの村から出ている先生ということで
それで能力ある人がもう選挙で勝てると思いますかね
だから私はちょっとこれ軽々で冗談ですけど
まあ選挙に勝った 勝ったならばね
おそらく最悪な人でしょうと
そこでこのブッシュさんが選挙もう随分前
私は冗談で言ったんですよ
今度も今度ブッシュさんが勝ちますよと言ったのは
もう本当はもう嫌味なんですよ
なぜかというと このもう一人の人が随分もう人気があって
マスコミもみんなこの人はもうどうせ当選したと同じことを言っていたんです
それで才能 能力を見ると
負けた人々はすごい上なんです
紳士 どう見たっても紳士なんです
勇気もある 金目当てはまるっきりない
で ブッシュさんの経歴やあれこれ見ると
もう丸入れるところは一つもないんですよ
全部バツばっかしで あ
だったらもう決まってるんだと
勝利は ブッシュさんが勝つんだと
私は冗談でも軽く嫌味で言ったんですけど
それが事実なんですよ
思った通りに勝ちましたから
だからこの政治の世界でも
これはもう日本やアメリカだけの問題じゃなくて
これはもう地球の問題で
どこでも同じなんです
で では会社でちゃんと
えっと 何て言いますか
あれはプロモーション
何でしたっけ？昇進 ちゃんと昇進するのはきちんと能力ある人ですかね
会社に対してどうしても必要な人で
そうじゃないんですよ
何のことなく 軽々く一番悪い人が昇進しちゃうんです
社会はどちらかというと
どちらかというとずるい人には居場所があるんですよ
ずるいことをできれば
もう結構居心地のいいところですよ
社会は 正直だったらかなり厳しいんです
これも現実なんです だから
習う世界 学問 能力の世界だと言ってますけど
そこから不公平な社会が出てきて
競争が成り立って 競争の世界で
でも能力ある人は勝てることではなくて
まあずる賢い知恵がある人が勝って勝ってしまって
自分の立場を維持するということになる
で スポーツの世界でも
このいろいろ何て言いますか
あのドラッグを使ったりもしちゃうし
もう法律で禁止していますけど
このオリンピックなんかで
この掃除する人々というのは
どんなゴミ箱でも注射器はいくらでもあるんだよと
そちらはただゴミ掃除して部屋の掃除して出ていくだけで
ということは この検査前にちゃんと検査を受けて
もう自分の部屋に戻って
次にもう競争に行かなくちゃいかんだからね
それでもう注射打って
と言ったりもする もしかすると今はね
まあ終わってからも検査するんだと思いますけどね
まあどうかわかりませんだけど
そこまで 競技に入る前に検査して
競技終わったらすぐ検査するとかね
そこまでなんでやってるのかというと
ずる賢い人が勝ち勝ってるんだからでしょうに
だからまあ悪知恵使う人はいろんなところで成功していくんだから
これ良くないんだから
あらゆる法律作ってなんとかうまくいかないのかと頑張ってはいるんだけど
うまくいかないんですよ
いくら法律作っても まだ何か抜け道を探すんですね
はい そういう世界が現れてきますね
学問から それでハードな道の主な産物
このハードな道というのは習う道なんですね
いろんなものを生んでくれますよ
まあ競争 戦い 戦争 その戦争までやっちゃうんだからね
知識の学問のせいで差別
いじめ 差別はどうせ生まれますよ
あの人には能力ない この人の能力あるっていうことになりますから
じゃあ差別で止まってもらえばいいんだけど
それいじめにまでいくんですよ
それで誰がいじめられますか？えっ？誰と
弱いではないんですよ
能力ある人もいじめられる
いじめる場合もあるし
能力ないんだからいじめる場合もありますよ
まあ結局弱い人といえば
それ正しい答えですけど
あの まあ弱い人はいじめるますけど
いじめられるんだから能力ないわけでもないんです
例えば日本の学校では
もし子供が英語でも喋れるんだったら最悪ですよ
もうどうなるかわからない
だからこのいじめまで現れてきます
搾取 まあそれはもう 明らかなこと
です 何か能力ある人は能力ない人を搾取するんですよ
何かもうくだらないもの
何か開発でもしたら まあすぐ特許を取って
例えば人間に必要な薬でも
まあそういうものは特許を取って
そんな高いお金取っていいのかと
苦労して研究したかもしれませんだけど
そういう方々は私はこの薬開発しましたと
みんな使ってくださいと言った方が正しいなのに
大体研究する人々はだいたいそういう気持ちでいるんですよ
とにかくこの病気を何とかして治したいと
だからもう何ヶ月間もものすごい苦労して
皆様に休みあるんですけど
そういう研究する人に休みさえないんですよ
1年中もう時間も関係ない
それで薬を作っちゃって
その会社かその組織がもうすぐ特許を取って
もう 500円の薬であろうとも
10万円で売っちゃうんですね
だからそれ悪くないでしょうと
お金かかったんだからと
悪くないんですよ もう患者さんにお金払えるならば
でもそういう世界じゃないでしょうに
搾取されてされて ほんのわずかな人々にしかそういう薬世界だから
大体知識やら研究やら何でもかんでも技術やらもう軍事技術やら何でも搾取するために使ってるんです
それから逆に言えば 食主義もそこから生まれてくるんですね
まあ同じことですけど
これと心は汚れるんですよ
習う世界ではもう必ず汚れる
だって自分に能力あったところで
自分をもう落とされちゃうと腹が立つでしょうね
もう悔しくてたまらんでしょうに
だからどうしても心が汚れる
あるいは競争で自分にはなかなか歯が立たない
何もできない そうすると何にも力のない無気力の人間で生きたくないでしょうに
しかし もう定めている競争で自分が当然負けちゃう
そうなるとその人も悔しいでしょうに
だから 怒り 憎しみ 嫉妬で苦しんでいる心が当然社会で現れてくるんです
それで見栄 高慢 自我 出張というものが出てくる
これ できる人々がね それで落ち込み
惨め 怒り 憎しみ そういうものはもう明らかに社会でもういっぱい
なぜかというと 競争社会だから
もう避けられない それも学問を習う世界から生まれてくる
まあ大事な産物なんです
しかし 悪いばっかりじゃないんですよ
良いところもあります
グッドアスペクトも道にも立場があるんですよ
あるあるんです 努力しないと学べないと人は成長しない
何も勉強しないと 何の努力もしないと
まあ動物のようでしょうに
だから人間として成長はしない
だからもう学ばなくちゃいけないことになります
成長するために それは一つ
学ぶ世界のいいところなんです
能力開発に社会の開発でもある
能力開発は 一人一人人間が自分の能力を開発することが社会全体の開発になるんです
それで社会全体 国全体良くなるんですよ
それも学問世界が与えてくれる良い結果なんです
知識は人に正しい道を教える
いろんなことを勉強して知識があれば
いつでももうこれが正しい
これをやってはいけないということはよくわかる
まあそれは別に仏教的な正しいということではなくて
普通の世界でどうすればいいかというね
そういうことは知識があればわかる
例えば国際的な何か調停しなくちゃいけないと
調停にもただの馬鹿どもたちが行っちゃうと
もう損失するでしょうね
すごい頭のいい ものすごい研究している
すごい人が言う 行っちゃうと正しくもうこちら側が損しないように
どちらでも納得いけるように話し合いをすることはできるんですよ
だから知識はもうだいたい正しいやり方
正しい道っていうのを教えてくれる
責任ある人間を育てる
知識ある人っていうのは
まあ一応責任がある人間になるんですね
社会でいろいろ上々行くんだから
それなりに責任も背負わなくちゃいけないし
だから頭の悪い人には責任を
なんて言いますか 背負うことはできないんですよ
あなたにこれこれお願いしますと言ったって
もう何するかわからない
知識のある人だったら
よくわかりましたと 責任を持って頑張りますということになるんですね
だから 我々のこの社会に責任感のある人間は必要なんですよ
それにそれがやっぱり知識
学問から出てくるもんなんです
無知迷信などで人は不幸になっているので
知識はそれを解決する
そこで人間というのは
もうインチキやら物語やら神話やら
幽霊の話 お化けの話 浦島太郎の話
そんなばっかしでしょうね
我々の歴史っていうのは
そういうことで 山に入るのは怖いわ
海に入るのは怖いわとかね
いろんな感情が出てきて
病気になったってでもこれは幽霊にもう憑かれているんだからとか
なんとか言われると もうどうすることもできなくなっちゃうし
もう神の罰が当たってるんだよと
あんた方にと言っちゃうと
まあどうすることもできなくなるし
そうやってこの無知のせいで
迷信のせいで 人類はものすごく
困っていたんです それがなくなってくれた
なくしてくれたのは学問
研究 科学なんですよ まあ私たちは仏教の国だから
そんなことは全然問題にしてなかったんですけど
ヨーロッパの歴史を見ると
まあ惨めも苦しいことももうありゃしないぐらいなんですよ
幸いに皆様方は偉い人々の歴史しか勉強していないんだからね
アレクサンダー大王やらあれやこれやとか
恐ろしい連中のそうじゃなくて
本当にヨーロッパ人が昔どんな生き方していたんでしょうかと
いうとすごい惨めなんですよ
ものすごい苦しい もう不潔で
このフランスはどうですかね
パリはもうちょこっと前に
ちょこっとって言ったって結構前なんですけど
まあみんな上へ建物作って
便所はそのまま道路に捨てる
道路は全然ない ものすごい悪臭
でも当時でもシャレなんですよ
まあそれは社会的なことで
特に宗教はどれほど人をいじめて魔女狩りまでしたりしてね
だからそういう恐ろしい迷信です
人々はもうもういじめて奴隷制度があって
もう信じられない苦しい社会でしたけどね
それを覚えた方がいいんですよ
今更我々にガチャガチャガチャガチャ言うんだから
まあ日本の方々に アジアとか自分の国でも期待はしてるんですけど
知識人でしょうし 力あるでしょうに
経済的な力あるでしょうに
ヨーロッパと肩並べているでしょうに
だったらもうなんでそんなもう椅子でももう３歩下げているのかと
堂々と言えばいいのに
もう言えるところないんですよ
僕 自慢できるところ だからまあ
アジアといろんなことを言ってますけど
もう男女平等でないとかね
もう誰ですかと聞きたいんだけど
平等でないのは だからこのそういういろんなことを
この科学的な世界ね 学問的な世界が発達して
智慧のある人々は社会でどんどん権力を握るようになってきて
バチカンではなくて 知識人が物事を言う
ローマ法の話ではなくて
誰かノーベル賞でも取った学者が何か発表しちゃうと
みんなそれを聞く時代になったんだから
結構いいんですよ それで
それで社会のかなり差別
いじめ 搾取 結構なくなったんです
ですから これはすごく大事なポイントなんですね
自然の管理までできて
自由を感じる 昔は何でも神様のご希望通りやと
まあ情けない生き方していたんですけどね
今はそうじゃないんです
子供が欲しいと言ったら
もうお医者さんに言って子供一人作ってくれと
作ってくれるんです 自分の奥さんにはちょっと体のちょっと異常があって妊娠できないんだけど
でも自分の子供欲しいやと言ったら
その女性から卵子を取って
他のお母さんのお腹の中でも育ててもらう
はい あなたの子供やと
で 自分の子供でしょうに
だからまあ なんとなく自分たちが自由やと
宇宙にも行けるでしょうに
だから今皆様はどちらでも
どこかでなんかまあ希望通りに生きられるんだと
運命のもうなんて言いますか
被害者じゃないんだと
運命なんかは変えられるんだよと
例えば貧しい家で生まれたっても
親がもう逃げられた子供であろうとも
まあ頑張って勉強でもしてね
やればもう結構成功する可能性はいくらでもあると
昔はできなかったよ その家の子でないと
決まってる家族でないと
だから自由はありますよ
それなりに それも知識のおかげなんですね
自然まで管理するんですね
幸福は知識がもたらす
だから結論として言えるのは
そういうわけで 我々今感じている幸福っていうのは
知識がもたらしたものなんです
前は悪口いっぱい言ったんだけど
悪いだけでもないんで
知識は幸福っていうものをもたらすんです
まあ知識にできないのは
この差別社会はいくら踏ん張っても
これを消すということはできないんですね
心汚れることを決して消すことはできないんですね
だからブッダは習う道も否定しないんですよ
タイトルは仏教は習うより慣れると言ったんですけど
それはもう私が作ってない
そのタイトルは  笑 でと言って逃げたってもね
賛成したでしょうと言えば
まあ一応あの否定してないんです
で あの生命にとって幸福
吉 吉祥って何？というお釈迦様に聞かれたんですよ
で どんな宗教家に聞いたっても
もうもう神を信じることとかね
お祈りすることとかね
そういうことを言うんだけど
ちゃんとあの 何でしたっけ？真言となることやとかね
なんか言うかもしれませんけど
お釈迦様は何言ったんですかね
この吉祥という言葉はマングラというパーリ語なんですけど
どちらかというと神秘系の単語なんですよ
もうはっきり言えばおめでたいって意味なんです
おめでたいっていうことですから
子供の延命しておめでたいっていうのは具体的でわかりますけど
ではなくて かなりこの神秘系のいろんなことは
ああいう風になったんだから
とてもおめでたいことやとかね
例えばこの 今日は仕事に北を方を見て出かけた方がおめでたいとかね
うまくいきますよと 南方向を向いて出ていけば
敵を倒せますよとかね
そういう考え方あります
中国にもある 日本にもあるし
インドにもあるし インドから来て自分の国もあるし
まあ裏で信じる人もいるし
表ではやってないんですけど
なんとなく神秘系の貴重
吉祥ですよ で お釈迦様はひとかけらも神秘的な言葉を言わなかったんです
それにすごい具体的に
一つはよく勉強しろよと
技術を身につけなさいよ
と それほど吉祥なことはないんだよと
で バーフサッチャンチャシッパンチ
その経典にたくさん吉祥 32ぐらいありますけど
まあリストはね 全部今日は関係ないんです
その中でこの これが一つで
バーフサッチャっていうのはもう学問的に学ぶこと
シッパっていうのはこの何か技術を身につくこと
それ両方やったら もうこれが最高な吉祥やと
最高なおめでたいことであると
負けませんと誰にも そこで仏教ではバフッストという単語よくあるんですよ
バフッストというのはよく勉強家という勉強しているんだということなんですよ
学者 知識人という意味なんですね
それは仏教では褒め言葉なんです
こうなんかサラサラとパーリの経典なんかを読んでみると
人を褒める時は本当に学者だったらバフッストという言葉をよく使うんです
この阿羅漢たちにもよく使っていて
だから仏教はよく勉強していることはかなり褒めるんです
否定してないんです そこで全く
勉強していない反対言葉はアッパスッタなんです
これはかなり非難的 非難とか否定的な人を非難するとき使う単語なんですよ
パーリ経典で誰かにアッパスッタなんか入ってきたら
まあお釈迦様にまあグタグタやられているということなんです
学んでいるものは少ないという意味ですけど
もう何も学んでいないという意味になります
だからブッダは学問なんか否定していると思ったら
これ違います だからブッダの言葉一つ勉強してみればわかります
アッパスッタヤン プリソバリワッドーワジーラティマンサーニタッサワッダンティパンニャータッサナワッデティ
学んでほとんど学んだことがない人は
牛のように老いる 肉体は太るが
知恵は成長しないと結構馬鹿にしていますよ
何も学んでいないと 肉体だけどんどん太って
そのまま衰えて死んじゃうだけで
か食べられるだけでね
牛みたいやと マクドナルドで終わると人生は
食べられて終わりますからね
で パンニャータッサナワッデティも知恵が成長しないんだと
だから明らかでしょ 仏教は学問認めているということは
習うことにブッダの答え
では 習うことにもすごい悪い側面があるでしょうね
恐ろしい側面がありますよ
心は汚れるわ 競争があるわ
戦争まで成り立つわ 借金あるわ
もうかなりもうどちらが重いかわからない
貢献する方が重いか 悪いところ重いかわからないでしょうに
今の我々は本当に現代社会のこの知識中心の社会で
我々は幸せか あるいは不幸の鈍足かとわからないでしょうに
だって小学生まで人殺しに行ってる世界でしょう
これっていいのか悪いのか
小学生いっせいに人殺すんだからといって
学校手を緩んでよろしいでしょうかと
あまり真面目に学問させないで
ちょこちょこと君たち遊んでもいいよと
そんなこと言っていいのかとさっぱりわからないんですね
だからお釈迦様は学問について何か答えを出してるんです
一番は たとえたとえ難しくても
厳しくても 習うべきものは習うんだよ
難しいとか厳しいとかね
こんなこと言うなよ なよ
情けないんだと 習わなくちゃあかんだったら
もうぐっちゃぐちゃ言わず
それはもうとことんもう習う
習った 習った方が学んだ方がいいんです
あるいは難しいんだから嫌やと言っちゃうと
仏教の世界ももうもうダメね
もうあんたはダメやと
出ていけと 人間らしからんと
だから全然甘くないんですよ
難しいっていうことに
しかし 何のためにやるのか
これ大事なんですよ 何のためにやるのか
は 仏教徒は常に念頭にしなくてはいけないことです
だから 難しい勉強でもやみくもにやるともう死にますよ
もう自殺したくなるんです
あるいは自分で自殺するのは怖いんだったら
他の人殺しちゃうんです
だからやみくもにやるんじゃなくて
何のためにこれやっているんでしょうかと
それを覚えておけば 難しいことに挑戦できます
役に立たないものは無意味です
そこで役に立たない勉強だったら
あ これも役にも立たないんだから
私は挑戦しないと堂々と言えばいいんです
この勉強は これは超難しいんだけど
やっちゃえば役に立つんだよと
だったらやります ということで
何するにも我々は何のためにやるのかっていうことは
ただそれだけ覚えておけば
この日本の社会にも アメリカ社会にも
ヨーロッパ社会にも あらゆる社会にある
この問題が解決しますよ
これは何のためにやっているのかという
習うことにいつでもこのプラグマティックということが大事なんですね
この時点でお釈迦様はすごいプラグマティックなんですね
プラグマティックというのは実用主義ですね
おそらく おそらくそれだと思う
わかりません いわゆる結果で判断する
役に立つ方 それだったらやるべきということ
それはブッダの答えでね
簡単そこでつまらないと思うんだったら次に行きます
さらにプラグマティックラーニングということね
習うことの目的 これが仏教の目的
アメリカの若者にあんたは何のために勉強するのかというと
くだらないことを言うかもしれませんだけどね
アメリカンドリームがあるんだぞとかね
あるいはアメリカは世界一強いやとかね
そんなのはもう正しい目的にはなりません
仏教から言う目的でいえば
幸福 平和 安穏 道徳的な人格向上
こういうものなんですよ
これ勉強すれば幸福になる
これ勉強すれば世界は平和になる
これ勉強すればいい人間になる
だったら いくら難しくてもそれにチャレンジしなくちゃいけないんです
だからアビダンマでも勉強しておいてください
結構難しいんですよ 並の難しさじゃないんです
一応幼稚園ぐらいのレベルのところまでは一応 1年
2年かけて私は説明しましたけどね
中学レベルでは喋ったことはないんです
アビダンマにあります
あれ結構ランクが 強いて言えば
習うことの目的は良い人間になることです
仏教では良い人間になることですよ
だったらあの問題全部解決する
良い人間は借金に行かない
良い人間は差別はしない
良い人間は他人をいじめませんよ
だから目的は良い人間になることだと思っておけば
いかにこの世界は楽かと思いますかね
学校の勉強で それはきれいさっぱり忘れていい会社に入ることが目的でしょうに
だから人間がわざと 自分で地獄の穴を開けてるんですよ
自分でそういう恐ろしいもう落とし穴に自分でよく胸を張って落とし穴に飛んでみるそうと
で 落とし穴に飛んだところで
あらゆる針に刺されて毒を回されて
あー苦しい 苦しい 苦しいと
なんで今更泣くんですかね
だから社会の問題というのは
人間が勝手にいい会社に入ることやと
金持ちになることやと
公務員になることやとかね
そんな恐ろしい目的を作って勉強しているんだから
勉強はもう明らかに地獄なんです
ブッダいうのは いい人間になることをよく覚えておくと
なぜならば もう経済的な幸福
そんなのは当たり前で
誰でも知っている 何か勉強した方が仕事は見つかるし
収入は得られるし それはごく普通なことで
教えるまでにもいかない
それぐらいのことは だから
それよりも人格向上ということを覚えた方がいいんですね
目的があれば たとえ道が苦しくても努力することができるんですよ
目的があると頑張れますからね
他人に勝つなどの即的な目的は悪だ
こんなものを作っちゃうと悪ですよ
他人に勝つと そういうわけで
他人より優れますよ 他人に勝ってしまいますよと思っちゃうと
その人は悪行為をしているんです
たとえ勉強したって たとえ受験していたって
これ誰に対しても競争して勝つためではなくて
自分がいい人間になるために
自分がまとめない 信頼できる立派な人間になるためにやっているんだよという思えば良い行為です
善行為です 悪行為すれば当然地獄に落ちるでしょうし
善行為すれば天界に行けます
はい 続きやります 自分に負けないために
自分に勝つために 自分を乗り越えるために習うのです
だから他人に勝つためじゃないんです
自分に負けないために
自分に勝つために 自分を乗り越えるために
もっといい人間になってやろうではないか
自分が情けない怠け者だと
頭が悪くて最悪やと 負けるもんかと
そんなもんに いうことで挑戦するんです
ライバルは自分自身です
自分の未熟な性格です
だから学問のライバルは自分なんです
自分の未熟な性格なんです
自分の怠けです 自分の無知です
それがライバルです だから周りはみんないい仲間なんですよ
愚か者は他人に勝つこと
他人より財力 権力 知識力あることを目指すんですよ
これが愚か者やることなんです
他人よりはなんて言っても
お金儲かろうとかね 他人より権力を握ろうとかね
知識力 あの人々よりよく頭のいい
もうなんて言いますか
あの学問的な肩書いっぱいたまってやるぞとかね
博士号 2つ  3つぐらい取ってやるぞとかね
そういうのはもう愚か者のやり方です
博士号なくても頭のいい人は世界では頑張ってますよ
いっぱいそういうものを持ってる人もいますけど
役に立たない 頭が悪い
えーと 汚れた目的は不公平な
争いに満ちた苦しみで溢れる社会を作るです
だから今我々生きている社会も不平等で
争いに満ちて苦しみで溢れている社会でしょうに
それは目的が汚れているんです
だから私は言うのは学問をやめなさいではなくて
目的を変えなさいということなんです
学問はそのまま目的だけ変える
いきなり社会がもうびっくりするほど良い社会になるんです
だから そのことについてブッダの言葉
私は今まで言ったのは
私の個人の考え方じゃないんですよ
お釈迦様の言葉をちょっと入れ替えただけ
アッ
ターハヴェージタンセイヨーヤーチャーヤンイタラーパジャーアッチャダンタッサポータッサーニッチャーサンヤタチャーリノーネーヴァデーヴォナガンダッボーナマ
ーロサハブラッモナージタンアパジタンカイラータタールーパッサジャントゥノー覚えやすい
本当にいいいい単語でしょ？発音しやすいでしょ
覚えてほしいんですよ
人間にそんなものは これこそ復元
なんて言ますか 他人に勝つよりは自分に勝つことが優れている
自分を戒めて落ち着いている
その人の勝利を奪うことは
神々にも心霊にも悪魔にも神様にもできませんと
仏教は神様さえ馬鹿にしてしまうんですよ
私の勝利を奪うことは
たとえ神様にもできんやと
たとえ悪魔にもできんよと
そういう勝利者になってほしいんですよ
では誰に勝つんですかというと
自分自身に勝つんです
他人に勝つより アッターハヴェージタンセイヨーヤーチャーヤンイタラーパジャ
こちらこちらいろいろないろんな人々
一般の人々いるでしょう
あの人に向かった この人に向かった
あの人に向かったとかね
何の意味もないんですよ
アホじゃないかと 仏教ブッダは言うんでしょうね
私は隣の国を攻めたとか
アレクサンダーがもうアジアまで来たんだけど
アホじゃないですか あいつは途中で死んじゃったんだからね
自分の国で楽々に贅沢していればよかったのに
完全に無知ですよ もうローマの歴史なんか読んでみると
こんなバカがいるのかと
エジプトの歴史やらね
ピラミッドの歴史やらね
相当バカ病気やと思うんでしょうに
王になったらパラオになったら
そいつは国を管理することじゃなくて
もうお墓を作ることに一生を使うんですよ
それ誰かに盗まれる それでお墓を作るために材料石がなかったら
他のピラミッドからパクってくるんです
そこで別のピラミッド
巨大な王様の像があるでしょ
そこを運んできて 首だけ取っちゃって
自分の首をそこに付けてつなげるんですよ
これがすごい人気あるエジプトの歴史なんですね
もうアホというと もうそんなことばっかりやっている
だからもう他人より勝った
他人より勝ったと言ったっても
もうもう犬に食われたり死ぬんですよ
毒殺されちゃって 寿命を全うすることはできない
だからお釈迦様はなんでそんなそんなことはと
だって自分の家でいる人に毒殺されるでしょうに
王様に毒を飲ませるために外から来られない
できないでしょうに それぐらい人にも負けてますよ
だから自分自身に勝ちなさいよと
その勝利はたとえ神様にも奪うことできんやと
だからブッダは神様さえも乗り越えなさいという話ですよ
それでまた続きます このプラグマティックラーニングという実用実用主義は
したがって 金儲かるための勉強
知識を増やすための勉強は仏教は評価しない
知識的に太るために勉強しなさいと言わない
あの肉体的に太ることにも
知識的に太ることも悪いんですよ
健康にスマートでないと
で 金儲かるための勉強っていうのは
これ悪人ですよ もうそういうのを仏教は評価しない
結果として勉強により苦しくなることも
高慢になったり 負けて落ち込んだりすることも起こりません
だからこういうこれをやめちゃえば
勉強で苦しい 苦しいということは言えないんですよ
なぜかというと 大事なことだからやらなくちゃと何か気分がいいんですよ
私は結構難しいことをやってますよと
これすごい大事ですよと
本当に勉強は苦しいのに
すごい快楽感というか
もう楽しみ感じるんですよ
大変だよ ものすごい難しいことに挑戦してるんだよと
私がやってる研究はもうなかなか誰もやってないんだと
だからやってるんだよと
いうことで 結構楽しいんですよ
苦しくならない 高慢にもならない
負けて落ち込むこともない
ブッダの道を歩めば 勉強は無駄になることはありません
目的さえあればね 目的さえあれば
勉強は決して無駄になりません
大体子供たち言うんでしょうにね
こんな数学やっても意味がないでしょうとかね
無駄じゃないんですとかと
目的があれば無駄なことはなくなるんです
ハードな道であっても充実感を感じる
勉強はハードな道ですが
それでも充実感を感じる
それまたそれの証拠なるブッダの言葉
サハッサマピチェーワーチャーアナッタパダサンヒター
このこれがよけ エーカンアッチャパダンセイヨーヤンソトゥワーウパサンマティー
エーカンアッチャパダンセイヨーヤンソトゥワーウパサンマティー
役に立たない 意味を持たない善の言葉よりも
聞いた人の心を落ち着かす
いわゆる育てる一言は優れている
だから人格向上という目的があれば
無駄な勉強は捨てるんですよ
だから無駄な勉強をいっぱいやっても意味がないんだと
人の人格向上する ほんのちょこっとの勉強でも最高に優れているんだよとブッダははっきりしているんです
役に立たない勉強は平気で捨てなさいよと
現代的に言えば 無意味な本を 1000冊読むよりはもう役に立つ本を 1 冊読んだ方が良いということなんです
これは現代的に入れ替えるとこんな意味になるんです
無意味な本をもう1000冊ももう1万冊も読んだって意味がないんですよ
自分の役に立つ本だったら 1
冊だけでも十分です それからもう一つ
ヨーバーローマンニャティバルヤンパンディトーワピテーナソーバーローチャパンディタマーニーサウェーバーローティウッチャティ
無知な人でも 自分が無知であることを知っているならば
それによって知識人になる
私は無知だとわかったら
それで十分 もう知恵が現れてきます
謙虚だから 無知なのに知識人だと思っている人は
本当の無知な人です あ
私はいろいろ知ってますけどとかね
勉強したこともありますよと
偉そうなことを言うと
本当は無知なんですけど
そんな態度をとると本物の無知になるんです
だから自分がそれほど知識がないんだと
それほど能力がないんだと知っていると謙虚になるでしょうし
だからといって怠け怠け者になるんじゃないんだから
仏教はそれ嫌だから だからまあちょっとできるだけのところをなんとかやってみますということで
どんどん知恵 知恵がもう向上して上達していくんです
いわゆるこの知ったかぶりでしょうかね
何でも知ったかぶり やりたくてやりたくなる人っていうのは明らかに無知なんですよ
人の話を聞かない すぐ愚痴を出すんです
それで学問に対して 結論
結論 1 と書いたんですけど
あの 2 の番号をつけるの忘れちゃった
まあそんなところでしょう
人は必ず学ぶべきものです
困ったね 学問学ぶ 習うよりは慣れるという話に来たんですけど
やっぱり学ぶべきものですよ
社会は豊かで幸福になることと
人格が向上するものを選んで学ぶのです
何でも学べない これ選ぶんですよ
社会は豊かで幸福になること
それ選んで学ぶんです
それから人格向上 これが一番大事ですよ
それになるのかと選んで勉強するんです
だからもうリラックスできますよ
だって何でも勉強しなくてもいいんだからね
心を清らかにするものを学ぶことは優先です
仏教は優先順位がいて
心清らかになることは何よりも大事だと
なぜかというと 死んでからもその影響あるんだからね
地理学を勉強したっても
まあ退職するまでですよ
その能力の役に立つのは
たとえエンジニアになっても
まあ歳になったところで会社から追い出されますからね
それからまあ庭の草取りしかやることないんですよ
宇宙開発していたっても
だから学問 学問ってのはそんなもんで
すぐ意味がなくなるんですよ
しかし 心清らかにすることを勉強しておけば
もう死んでからでも 死後でも
もうずっと自分の役に立つ
ですから これは一番最優先ですね
人類に役に立つ知識でも
悪人にはその知識を戦争に人を不幸に陥れるために使用するからです
なんでこれ優先ですかというと
これやるんだからなんです
知識は悪人の手に渡してみてください
どうなるのかと 例えばコンピューター知識あるでしょうに
これが悪人が上達しちゃうと
ハッカーになるでしょうに
いろんなデータをデータバンクに侵入するわ
人のデータは盗み取るわ
もう金は盗むわ 自分の家でいて外へ出られないで
だから物事を悪人の手に渡すと
たとえ立派な技術であっても
立派な科学であっても
やってる人は悪人だったらもうとんでもないことになるんです
だから世の中で人間楽々に移動できる新幹線みたいな乗り物やら
そういうものよりも恐ろしい開発は武器でしょうに
だいたい科学能力のまあ 7割
8割は軍事開発に使ってるんです
だから世の中はずっと不幸なんです
10ドル以下ですよ 地雷というんですか
あれ 1個は あんなものは作って
バンバン作って売っちゃって
時々それの作り方まで教えてあげたりする
しかし 人間に役に立つ
役に立つ 何か薬とか何とか
教えてません あげません
それは企業秘密や それは教えてくれない
ピストルの作り方だったら
もうすぐデータ手に入ります
秘密はありません 爆弾の作り方とか
精密にデータがあります
開示しています だから悪人の手に知識を渡しちゃうと
そういうことになるんです
それは仏教 すごく大変なことであって
とにかくやめてほしいと
だから子供は悪人か善人かわからないでしょうに
だから教育の初めからもう人格向上は大事にするんです
そうすると 子供はもう悪人でも善人でもなんでもないんだから
もう善人として成長するんです
道徳は捨てているんだから
学校教育から 自然に悪人になるんです
それは心の法則 それは後で最後に説明します
心は本来悪ですよ 子供も悪なんですよ
だから人格向上で良い人にしなくちゃいけないんです
まあそういうことであるんだから
仏教はまあこれが優先にするんです
善人の手でのみ知識は輝く
それは最終結論 善人の手でのみ知識は輝くんです
人類にとって 太陽のごとく
みんなに明るさと命を与えてくれるんです
知識は それは知識を持っている人が心綺麗な善人である場合なんです
なかなか今の世界ではそうはならないんですけど
結論が終わったところで
すぐに飛びますかね  はい